there is a congressman named Greg Meeks
who recently announced that he's
supporting Michael Bloomberg in the
Democratic primary now Gregory Meeks is
a Democrat and he is black and Bloomberg
has been having some issues lately with
comments about stop and frisk and black
Americans and so these endorsements from
minority members of Congress are really
important to Michael Bloomberg being
able to continue crafting a narrative
that is something other than the vile
racist which has been the
characterization of Bloomberg over the
last couple of weeks well Greg Meeks is
helping to craft that narrative he
showed up on CNN he pulled the tired old
but Bernie isn't a Democrat talking
point which is a lame talking point to
start with because it's not about issues
it's just a party membership argument
it's a form of exclusive tribalism but
it's extra hilarious because Bloomberg
just changed from being a Republican to
being a Democrat so there's a ton to
talk about here let's first watch the
clip notice that Greg Meeks doesn't talk
about any policy here doesn't talk about
who's better on health care who's better
on economics nothing it's just Bernie
isn't really a Democrat take a look the
difference for me is Bernie Sanders is
not a Democrat so I don't understand why
Bernie Sanders who does not want to
become a member of the Democratic Party
vowed he would run and if he wins rule
you know though his ID as a Democrat run
as a Democrat we've asked him on a
continuous basis if in fact you want to
be the Democratic nominee you should be
a Democrat if you're not a Democrat you
should not run he should run as an
independent he's not a Democrat so to me
I wouldn't allow a Republican to run as
a Democrat or for the Democratic nominee
allowed to run you should be a Democrat
I think that he should say if he wants
to be a Democrat he said register in the
Democratic Party and then you can talk
about running and to be my
representative I want a Democrat to be
my representative as president of the
United States he might not be doing it
and he raised a whole lot of money what
you'll see what happened thank you very
much god bless okay so first of all
debate the
issues if you support Bloomberg and not
Bernie argue why Bloomberg is better
than Bernie on the issues what's their
position on health care on education on
inequality on taxation on foreign look
whatever just pick a topic and argue why
the person you're supporting is better
than Bernie if that's what you want to
argue repeating what was it four times
there in a minute that Bernie isn't a
Democrat is not an argument I don't care
about tribalism and party but then it's
layer two which is if you want to play
the party game Bloomberg was a Democrat
until 2001 then became a Republican to
run for mayor then became an independent
in 2007 to continue this sort of persona
of the independent thinker and then
became a Democrat in 2018 just a year
and a half ago presumably as a pretext
for what he is now doing running for the
Democratic presidential nomination so
it's all BS and the reality is meek says
well Bernie should just switch to being
a Democrat now if he was running in the
Democratic primary if Bernie did that
they would say Bernie's pandering if
Bernie Sanders took this guy's advice
said I am going to become a Democrat if
he did it then Greg Meeks would be
saying this is pandering I don't I want
a real Democrat not a guy who switches
his nomination his party registration
just to run for president which is
exactly what the guy he's supporting did
Michael Bloomberg so it can't win for
Bernie on this Greg Meeks would be the
first to say Bernie is only switching to
pander but then because Bernie did not
switch party registration Meeks says
well he's not really a Democrat I want
to vote for a Democrat but then the most
important thing again is that none of
this has to do with who's going to be
better for you on wages who's going to
be better for you on health care if a
Republican ran with the right policies
against Trump I'd support the Republican
now in reality no one with those
socially Democratic policies that I
support would be a Republican in 2020
United States but it's besides the point
I don't care about party registration
note also that Bernie is in the
Democratic leadership in the Senate he's
not just some outsider who has no
integration with the
kradic party so it's a circular firing
squad argument it will never get
anywhere anyone who makes this argument
already shows they don't really care
about reason and rationality and then
the problem is anyone who tries to argue
with somebody like Greg Meeks about this
is also going to fail because it's an
unwinnable argument no matter what they
will say why Burnie is wrong in this
particular case and then zoom out as of
December 2019 Gallup says only 28% of
Americans are registered Democrats so
what exactly are you trying to do by
saying if you aren't part of the club we
don't want you when seventy-two percent
of the country isn't part of that club
and is not a demo aren't registered
Democratic voters it's pointless
tribalism and it doesn't actually deal
with the issues which is what I care
about tell me what you think about this
Bernie's not really a democrat meme that
is continuing to sort of spread like a
virus in some circles let me know on
Twitter
I am at D Pakman follow me there one of
our sponsors today is VIN Chara watches
giving you 15% off your entire order
when you go to david pakman.com slash
watch don't pay thousands of dollars for
a high-quality watch that looks great
because you don't have to all of in
Charro's watches are made with high-end
materials masterfully built and they
look like something you'd spend a ton of
money on but ever even Cheryl watch
ranges from about a hundred and fifty to
three hundred bucks I went over to their
website and picked out the bellwether
and silver and white really nice elegant
look it's a coronagraph style wore it to
a gala over the weekend and a lot of
people ask me where's the watch from
really really great look totally
different they also sent me the altitude
in matte black and red a much more
rugged view of what a watch can look
like really liked it as well as well as
the athletic strap it's a new year it's
a new decade it's time to re-establish
your style add something new to your
look and a high-quality watch is the
perfect way to do that you can get
15% off Finch arrows entire collection
when you go to david pakman.com slash
watch